for instance it's almost certain that
Neanderthal man played and they would
have been competitive d arick doc most
scientists are sure that they spoke for
a long time scientists believe
Neanderthals wore only animal skins they
couldn't have made clothes because no
needles with eyes were found in their
caves but a simple spike will be enough
to make holes in leather and fur through
which strips of hide and sinews could be
threaded for a long time Neanderthals
were thought to have lived in unhygienic
conditions but there's hardly any sign
of tooth decay in the undertale' remains
they may have known more about personal
hygiene than we give them credit for but
ideas about the level of Neanderthal
development have been revolutionized by
one astonishing discovery
long before Homo sapiens our own
ancestors came to Europe Neanderthal man
invented and manufactured an
extraordinarily effective blew the
Museum of prehistory in Halle has its
own supply of Ice Age adhesive
this fragment was found in the 1960s as
a dig in conics our in eastern Germany
but it was years before the researchers
realized what they had this glue is
proof of the lay under Thomas remarkable
inventiveness and have a genuine
neanderthal technology everyone thought
it was just a piece of pitch
no one believed the Neanderthals could
have made an adhesive out of simple
birch bark
and there were good reasons it's very
difficult to make even with modern
equipment
dr. Christian Heinrich one dalish has
tried but the Zephie Lafourche endure
many different chemical reactions are to
take place at the same time and the
process has to take place very fast this
isn't easy to achieve even in a Test
youth I had to have several goes before
I even got it halfway right and each
time it turns out differently it's hard
to imagine how a Neanderthal man managed
without a Bunsen burner and without a
test youths in the combat only ones of
men are born early against us no
scientists has succeeded in making this
pitch glue with the materials
Neanderthals could have used but a
chance discovery among a Native American
tribe in Canada has given a very strong
idea how they must have done it
they put tightly rolled strips of birch
bark in a hole in the ground good
oh no next they packed it with earth to
keep out the air
Oh God then they applied a smoldering
stick dire
first it emitted a pleasant smell like
smoked pork and then the birch bark
deprived of oxygen sweated out the
valuable pitch if any air was let in the
bark would catch fire and the process
would be ruined it wouldn't have gone
right every time especially while you
were learning